[Música]
hola me ayudan a salir
hola hoy no otra vez encerrada
ay sí sí soy yo viste otra vez gracias
quiero compartir con ustedes una
historia y esa historia empieza con esto
que tengo en la mano una manigueta
impresa en 3-d
resulta que empezaron a perderse algunos
objetos en la oficina
y la solución administrativa que nos
dieron fue ponernos un jabón de
seguridad maravilloso
lo que pasó fue que una vez que teníamos
el llavín no había forma de que esa
puerta una vez que lo celebrábamos se
abriera
todo mundo se quedaba encerrado en la
oficina
empezamos entonces a analizar posibles
opciones para resolver esa situación y
entre las que se nos ocurrieron estaba
una que era entrenar una paloma que
llevara los mensajes de ayuda a los
vecinos aledañas porque resulta que en
esa oficina la señal era tan mala tan
mala que no podíamos mandar mensajes
tampoco esa no era una opción la otra
opción fue tirarnos por la ventana
teníamos una ventana enorme por la que
podríamos tirarnos ya habíamos medido la
altura que había de la ventana a la
acera que era lo que estaba ahí abajo
la otra opción era esperar tres meses a
que nos comprarán una manigueta para
poder mover la puerta de a trabajarla y
salir o entrar
estando en ese profundo análisis un
compañero viene y nos dice oigan y por
qué no usamos la impresora 3d que
acabamos de comprar
e imprimimos nuestra propia manigueta y
todos dijimos qué buena idea hagamos eso
y eso fue lo que hicimos y esa manigueta
es esta es exactamente hasta que tengo
la mano
cuando nosotros decimos eso no solo
solucionamos esa situación que teníamos
sino que además le abrimos la puerta a
las enormes posibilidades que nos
brindan las nuevas tecnologías
y entre esas tecnologías está la
impresión 3d está el corte láser y está
la electrónica open source como el
arduino y el raspberry y muchas otras
que durante estos cuatro años hemos
tenido en el laboratorio
lo que no podíamos imaginar es que
además de eso le estábamos abriendo la
puerta a dos elementos que son
fundamentales cuando nosotros queremos
innovar en cualquier parte pero sobre
todo en instituciones públicas y esos
elementos son las personas y las
pasiones
y quiero aquí hacer un paréntesis para
hablar de dos conceptos
uno es
el de pasión y el otro es el de
innovación si nosotros pensamos en esos
conceptos vamos a tener muchas formas
diferentes de definirlos
de pensarlo de imaginar los de soñar los
y sobre todo de ejecutarlos
lo que yo hoy vengo a compartir con
ustedes es una nueva pero comprobada
forma de hacer innovación en una
institución pública
esas son algunas de las formas que yo en
las que yo me imagino esos dos conceptos
pero cuando yo lo comparto con otras
personas
se agregan otros elementos y esa es la
riqueza de este camino que nos lleva
hacia la innovación las diferencias y
las vivencias y las oportunidades y las
situaciones y las personas que van a
estar en esos caminos y todo esto va a
ir variando y va a ir adaptando se va a
ir creciendo
vamos entonces a imaginar a pensar ya
construir esa nueva forma de hacer
innovación y vamos a hacerlo con
acciones les voy a decir cuáles son las
cuatro acciones que nosotros hemos
ejecutado en la uned específicamente en
el laboratorio de fabricación para
innovar la primera acción
para innovar hay que alterar
y nosotros hemos alterado procesos hemos
alterado procedimientos y debo admitir
que hemos alterado personas a algunas se
les ha alterado la presión el azúcar el
de los triglicéridos el colesterol o sea
hemos tenido casos variados pero
esas personas son precisamente las que
en este momento más nos apoyan en el
camino de la innovación
y lo que hicimos fue invitar a personas
como don jose de diferentes áreas de la
uned de la oficina de contratación y
suministro de contabilidad de la
dirección de tecnología de la dirección
de producción de materiales de registro
los compañeros de seguridad como un jose
ojos es un guarda de seguridad en la
uned a que participarán en talleres de
arduino y de impresión 3d
ellos lo hicieron no solo por voluntad
propia sino en tiempo fuera de horario
laboral y aunque al principio yo pensaba
que lo que yo no era edad vamos a ver
qué es lo que hace esta gente que
molesta tanto
lo que ellos querían era entender como
esas tecnologías que estaban llegando a
la uned impactan a la universidad
impactan a los estudiantes pero más
importantes querían entender en que los
puede beneficiar a ellos ya su vida y
eso fue lo que encontraron en el caso
don jose por ejemplo él tenía una
recomendación médica de hace poco de que
tenía que buscar una forma de
entretenerse y de ocupar su tiempo por
salud y eso lo encontraron él arduino
hasta el día de hoy don jose ahora ya se
compró el kit ya no haya nuevos el del
laboratorio ahora tiene su propio kit y
sigue creando soluciones para su casa y
personales utilizando esas tecnologías
que conoció ahí
primera acción alterado
la segunda acción es que para innovar
hay que inquietar y eso es lo que ha
pasado con los funcionarios que trabajan
en el laboratorio de fabricación
como el caso de esteban resulta que
estébanez productor audiovisual es
comunicador y siempre he tenido una
obsesión con las luces
en su interacción con las tecnologías
descubre que hay muchas posibilidades de
integrar esas luces a diferentes
soluciones por medio del video mapping y
por medio del led mapping y entonces
esteban no sólo entiende eso sino que se
enamora de eso y crea producciones e
interviene edificios y crea producciones
como esta que creó para el congreso
[Música]
y es que yo veo esa foto esteban y
pienso que esteban yo tengo 8 años de
conocerlo y en realidad yo nunca lo he
visto reírse con esa alegría con esa
como esta en esa foto entonces esto
también digamos cuando la gente empieza
a descubrir eso y de verdad le gusta lo
que hace entonces eso es natural verdad
bueno ahí está este vago adicto lo van a
ver que no se ve tanto
en las este link este link es
programador
y sterling tenía antes de llegar al
laboratorio el trabajo que era programar
sistemas a la medida
ahora sterling programa soluciones para
la realidad aumentada soluciones para la
realidad virtual fue parte del grupo que
se hizo a nivel mundial que se capacitó
durante seis meses intensivos del cual
este link obtiene un título que dice que
es capaz de hacer casi cualquier cosa
con fabricación digital y óigame eso es
una bendición porque es muchísimo más de
lo que estábamos acostumbrados a pedirle
cuando era solo programador entonces eso
ha sido una bendición que tenga ese
título eso que ustedes ven ahí es el
proyecto en el que stalin está
trabajando ahora está programando una
solución de realidad virtual
que integra física matemática con valer
con tecnología y todo eso en el teatro
nacional
ellas son ana maría y carolina
y en el trabajo en el laboratorio van
descubriendo que tienen una pasión que
comparten que es el diseño de moda
ellos llevan cursos de eso pero ya en el
laboratorio lo aplican lo que han
conocido y además lo que saben de sus
profesiones
para crear vestuario y para crear
elementos que integran placas sensores
actuadores que reaccionan a diferentes
estímulos como este que me hicieron para
que viniera hoy
y que reacciona a amigos entonces es un
ejemplo de lo que ellas hacen y eso los
utilizamos como ustedes ven ahí lo
llevamos al congreso de tecnología en
lugar de hacer un stand y le mostramos a
la gente cómo la tecnología va cambiando
y la podemos ir integrando a diferentes
elementos
tercera acción para innovar hay que
transformar y quiero compartir con
ustedes dos de los casos de
transformación más significativos que
nosotros hemos conocido en el
laboratorio los estoy encandilando
me lo apagó
ok ok
el primero es
el de karen pamela
karen pamela es una mujer de 24 años
tiene dos niñas una de 7 años y otra de
2 años karen llega al laboratorio porque
tiene una idea que quiere hacer realidad
y esa idea es una cobija o una manta que
tenga diferentes sensores y elementos
que le permitan a su bebé
no solo estimularse en diferentes
sentidos sino también sentirse cerca de
su mamá cuando la mamá está trabajando
por medio de audios por medio de cuentos
por medio de música que comparten cuando
están juntas
karen no sólo logra hacer realidad su
proyecto sino que también lo escala y
actualmente karen vende no sólo la
comida sino otras adaptaciones que ha
hecho de esos de ese proyecto y los
vende por el facebook es una página de
facebook y por ahí los venden pero karen
no sólo transformó logró su proyecto y
lo transforma sino que también
transforma su vida porque cada vez se da
cuenta que es muy buena en la parte de
programación y en la parte de
electrónica y se cambia de carrera
pero además de cambiar de carrera deja
su trabajo
además deja la pareja y además cambia la
vida de sus hijas y cambia la vida de
sus hijas porque ahora ella comparte
estas tecnologías con sus hijas
ella también comparte en línea los
vídeos donde está con sus hijas y ya las
tías a gustar el albino y sabe hacer
cosas con el arte
el otro caso de transformación es el
dejaron harold es funcionario de hélice
en turrialba es estudiante de la unet y
harold empieza en el mundo de los
arduino porque yo nunca ha entendido
porque la verdad es que no entiendo qué
le pasó con la llave del carro pero no
podía ser claro con las llaves las
perdió la quebró no sé entonces ahora se
crea una aplicación y uso mar duino y
así encendía el carro con esa aplicación
en formular bien actualmente de harold
está haciendo esto en su casa
siente apagar las luces de su casa abre
o cierra las ventanas de su casa usando
arduino eso es un proyecto de
licenciatura
pero harold y su esposa han llevado la
transformación a otros niveles porque
ellos todos los miércoles en el centro
universitario de la uned en turrialba
dan talleres de arduino y de impresión
3d para niños jóvenes y adultos porque
los dos están convencidos de que es
cierto las tecnologías nos transforman
pero esta transformación tiene que
compartirse si queremos que de verdad
impacte y eso es lo que ellos están
haciendo en tu real
cuarta acción
para innovar hay que perturbar y cuando
nosotros escuchamos esa palabra casi
siempre la vivimos en ambientes
negativos pero en el caso de la
innovación es necesaria porque es la
forma que tenemos de sacar a la gente de
las zonas de confort en la que
normalmente caemos y sobre todo en
instituciones públicas eso nos nos
tiende a pasar porque casi siempre
cuando nosotros llegamos a queremos
cambiar algo a pedir algo diferente la
respuesta que nos dicen cuando uno le
dice pero por qué pero esto es lo que
hay
limón entonces tenemos que perturbar y
nosotros hemos perturbado el orden
institucional y les voy a dar dos
ejemplos de cómo hicimos eso
resulta que se nos ocurre comprar una
impresora 3d durante seis meses hicimos
todo el proceso que había que hacer que
la partida que se iba en esta que si la
otra que sí bueno etcétera hacemos todo
el proceso y los compañeros ya llegamos
al almacén que ya era como el último
paso y nos dicen ok
está bien vamos a recibir la primera
impresora 3d necesitamos saber cómo es
cómo se ve que las partes que como
vienen que como no bueno les damos un
proceso de inducción según nosotros
bastante claro les mandamos fotos les
enseñamos vídeos les decimos todo todo
pues el día que llega a la impresora nos
damos cuenta que se nos olvidó un
detallito que la impresora venía como
ustedes la ven a la derecha desarmada
ustedes no tienen idea del caos que se
hizo ese día los aturdidos y perturbados
fuimos nosotros nos llamaron las
autoridades nos llamó los compañeros de
almacén el proveedor nos llamó y nos
dijo que lo habían devuelto que lo
estaban acusando de vender los datos por
liebre quien no le quisieron recibir la
impresora que bueno usted no tiene ni en
el drama que se hizo pero al final
logramos recibir la impresora
y ahí ya ustedes la avena ya está
armando las guías en la impresora con la
que imprimimos esta manita que es parte
de esta historia
segundo caso
se nos ocurre que le queremos dar un kit
de arduino a los estudiantes de un curso
para que hagan su proyecto final
cuando estamos negociando eso nos dicen
que esos
se cataloga como material didáctico y
que entonces entra en esa partida pero
resulta que no me pregunten por qué pero
esa partida implica que tiene que haber
papel en algún lado y resulta que el kit
de ordino no tiene papel en ningún lado
entonces cuando nosotros llegamos y les
enseñamos que era nos dicen no así no se
puede porque entonces no se puede meter
en esa partida y no se va a poder
entonces nos volvemos a asentar en
aquella profunda mesa de análisis de
cuando estábamos resolviendo lo de la
manigueta nos sentamos y entonces les
digo yo oigan pero ésta no puede ser una
solución tecnológica chiquillos hay que
meterle papel donde se les ocurra ese
kit en algún lado tenemos que meterle
papel y entonces alguien uno de los
compañeros dice tip hagamos como un
manual
entonces lo que pasa es que demasiados
manuales en línea o sea no tenía sentido
entonces lo que hicimos fue poner que
para proteger el ambiente y vamos a
sugerir los manuales en línea y pusimos
unos códigos qr y pusimos los manuales y
además pusimos cuidado del kit que ahora
los vemos y sinceramente nos venimos a
ningún estudiante se recurriría a hacer
lo que nosotros pusimos ahí con el kit
no lo moje no le ponga nada encima o sea
cosas como verdad pero doblamos el papel
lo metimos en el que fuimos y lo
presentamos y nos dijeron ahora sí ya se
les puede dar y entonces hasta el día de
hoy los estudiantes tienen su kit con el
papelito incluido pero tienen su kit
para desarrollar los proyectos del curso
entonces
cuando nosotros pensamos en este camino
que les he tratado de resumir y que
hemos recorrido y que es el camino de la
innovación en una institución pública
volvemos a la manigueta porque hay
momentos que son muy cansados que son
agotadores que nos desaniman a veces que
son difíciles
pero pensamos en la manigueta y en todo
lo que logramos cuando le abrimos la
puerta a las personas a las pasiones a
las tecnologías
y todo vale la pena
y pensamos que todo ha valido la pena y
vemos todo eso y recorremos el camino y
seguimos adelante
y yo estoy segura de que la innovación
es posible en una institución pública no
solo porque durante cuatro años hemos
logrado eso en la uned sino porque
durante 35 años yo tuve a la par a una
persona que me enseñó que eso era
posible y esa persona es funcional fue
funcionario de lista durante 40 años de
su vida y fue en el liceo donde conoció
la primera computadora donde conoció la
primera llave maya donde conoció el
primer teléfono en el que se podían
dejar mensajes que eran
queda maravilloso y no sólo lo conoció
sino que le impactó y lo alteró y lo
inquieto y eso lo llevó a compartirlo
con nosotros
con su familia
porque era mi papá
con su comunidad
y entonces en esos momentos difíciles yo
me vuelvo y pienso si él pudo derecho
eso hace 40 años en él y sé por qué él y
se le permitió todo eso qué es lo que no
podemos hacer ahora
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]